arriveront à kadhafi
on
[Musique]
m
c'est parfois à l'occasion d'un simple
contrôle d'identité on voit que la
personne incriminée en la ménopause en
interrogeant l'obligent à donner le mot
de passe sautée d'efforts on regarde son
téléphone ces conversations on trouve
des photos de lui en train d'en passer
un mail ou un truc comme ça dans des
vidéos porno gay sur son téléphone pour
eux c'est suffisant pour qu'on prive de
son homosexualité
et là il passe au test annales pour
confirmer son homosexualité il se fait
condamner
[Musique]
nos recommandations s'est immédiatement
mettre terme être terme aux tests de
langues qui examen de lente
[Musique]
dans la réalité dans l'est dans les
affaires qui sont devant la justice à ce
type de test de l'anus des personnes et
anton est encore en train d'être
utilisée comme moyen de preuve mais ne
sait comment je dîne à travers les rails
face à la